[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
do you have a vision
do you write [ __ ] down i do have a
vision board actually and i want a black
sun one day i have two black kids on my
vision board
you have two black kids yeah okay so
people always i don't tell people that
often because they don't see it the way
i see it you know how do you see it i
see it as these are going to be my son
these gonna be my sons one day i think
other people see like oh a guy from the
south has a couple of black guys on a
vision board you know i think they kind
of get a
you know they're looking at it
differently so if i went to your house
and looked at the vision board you got
two two black kids up there yeah yeah
yeah look
they're happy and one of them has a
school book under his arm
those are my sons man
okay
no you look well put together i mean we
do when i used to party and a lot of my
listeners know this i used to you know
get a little bit of drugs and i would
you know i had a vest i would i bought
i probably bought about six thousand
dollars worth of vests bro vests yeah
you went out of vespa oh
spree i'm that armless adventure bear
bro i'll be out there
do you ever hug somebody in a vest bro
with nothing else on i have it's pretty
good
i got into it that's the original
honeymoon bro that's a greek honeymoon
right there
you're right a vest but no i would spend
that's what i spent my money on and
yeah
over time now as i get older this is
like i collected you know some people
collect you might collect nice jackets
you know you know some people are shoe
guys like that's one thing i would like
i had vests like for some reason i got
into it about eight years ago and i've
had a collection over the years so are
you still whipping out those vests not
as much i would do drugs at night by
myself at home and put them on bro you
would put a vest on to do drugs
not do the drugs first i think
the best yeah that's came after the best
for a byproduct i think is some of my
behaviors like i like someone's taking a
bird scooter to the gym in the morning
you know and i don't have nice calves
and i have shorts on so for me it's
really humbling you know
bro taking [ __ ] lean calves out for a
spin on a bird scooter 39 years old bruh
have you have you felt at all
safe on that thing
i did it once or twice and it just the
you know
one bump and it's over right yeah
there's not a lot of um
there's not a lot of opportunity for
safety i don't feel like on them overall
dude one lady hit the dirt bro by the
sprouts over by me right this lady
[ __ ]
way too old to be on one had a bag of
groceries just hit the dirt bro and just
didn't move at all right instead of
helping there was like two people
yelling this [ __ ] is down over here
right and i was like oh my god
yeah i at least haunt my horn real loud
as i [ __ ] drove off you know but she
but she bit it man groceries all over
like um
yeah it's a lot of well listen these
birds
you know it's it's it's good for you
want to go to the gym you want to go to
a buddy's house fine you pick one up you
go but what i've seen on these birds is
like you were saying people are carrying
groceries
then i saw a guy
that apparently the you take a burden
you you go and charge it right and
people make money the guy was on a bird
with two birds
on his shoulder okay
uh it's just it's not made for that you
know what i'm saying that's so [ __ ]
bro that's crazy dude
when you flocking man that's
rocking the birds that's crazy
yeah somebody will see some guy at night
just throwing them all into a [ __ ]
van you know
and this is one of your moves bro stolen
from you right
you buying probably tomato farms and
stuff what are you buying
nick was a premature baby so he never
he's got a lot of uh congenital issues i
notice and this is probably the italian
in me uh-huh i don't like
that you got your name outside on the
wall yeah i i think it should be
non-descript yeah don't don't trust it
because yeah kind of some psychotic and
then oh this is where he podcasts out of
you know kind of like
a little under the radar no that's a
good idea actually i think also because
there's a lot of mental health in this
building
so it's like
yeah i think they're all gonna get one
you know one of those freaking brain
hamsters relapses and next thing you
know they come nibbling through the door
you know i'm the first guy they go after
uh
yeah but yeah that's the italian you man
right you guys do hide and go seek like
every day it's like almost 24 hours a
day that's right no no one never knows
where we're at yeah you know
you've got a sign out there it might as
well be a neon yeah
i'm never like these positive guys that
you see up on um on instagram like a
gary vee or the rock or whatnot mark
wahlberg that whole thing like hey man
you got to get up i'm not that guy i'm
the guy who is
you know i'm waiting to fall off the
mountain rather than to climb up it yeah
and that's what kind of keeps me
motivated
like you're paying like you're talking
to the trash guy like look just let me
know there's some openings over there
like you're playing in the head so we
haven't even talked about the the shirt
i think
i wore this shirt just for you man it's
a beautiful piece uh it's a beautiful
garment well i remember you said that
yeah if you ever had a different job it
would be like a concierge or something
that's right so i could just see you
like i'll tell you this if you show up
in people's dreams or anything this is
what you this is what they're wearing
this is what i'm wearing
definitely
dude so how much you must have crazy
money now you got money and your
italians you probably have like your
baby hiding it around the house and
stuff i bet you because i watch your
instagram videos man they're they're
great it's nice to see you with the
family and everything yeah and you you
know being able to achieve a lot of your
dreams and stuff but i bet low-key
you guys are doing some crazy stuff at
night around there hiding cash under the
floors and stuff you know well if you
know anything about italians we we don't
talk money
so uh but things are good i'm really
enjoying my family and um yeah man it's
it's been really really nice to uh
you know we've talked over the years in
regards to like this business yeah how
you you know breakthrough and whatnot so
it's it's been a long long road but
after 20 years finally starting to kind
of peek my head out of the ground and uh
yeah getting some fans out of the ground
at the bank bro i don't know if you know
uh this is a financial shot
no i don't have an office right i just
have a
a home and i'd work out of the home
right but it's getting a little crazy
now at the house with two children two
kids it's hard to work it's hard to do
anything so what i've been doing is
going to my gym and after i work out i i
set up shop at the gym at the gym oh
jesus
which i've done
i've i've gone to starbucks i've got you
know i've done all that stuff you know
throughout my whole career yeah
yeah i've always kind of like just set
up shop and and and did things so what
are you bringing a laptop are you
bringing like a laptop okay no i'm not
bringing a printer okay okay but uh i
just just you know catch up on some
emails on a table
outside the gym right i could just see
you carrying a monitor in there yeah no
not that you just have a guy a coffee
bean would bring a monitor in yeah he
had that stack at tower that whole thing
was insane the same guy that's editing a
football
movie at apple store you see those guys
you walk in this guy's doing like he's
on
final cut doing uh doing his uh
short film yeah he's like well everybody
quiet down i need some room tone
chill the [ __ ] out guy
trying to get some air pods man you know
what you know what i'm gonna have to do
yeah i typically don't do this i gotta
take off the podcast jacket it's getting
a little is it really we'll hang it up
for you i'm going to get up and hang it
up okay
because i'm getting heated talking about
money
[Laughter]
it's not my audience i mean it excuse
younger yeah my audience is typically
you know 30 to 60. i have a jag off dude
you know what i'm saying bro jack also
cufflinks i know what your audience is
it's getting hot in podcastville bro
getting high i'm joking we're eat your
pizza out here there's a nice place
called pizana out here if you're looking
for a nice piece of pizza is there yeah
where's that at it's on robertson and
melrose they just opened up a location
also in brentwood i have no money and no
steak in this place but okay if you want
some pizza those are nice neighborhoods
bro i'm eating pizza more out here in
regional you know i'm eating pizza more
are you i don't i don't want to tell the
listeners or the viewers where we're at
right but uh yeah i eat pizza around
here okay this is your hood like really
close to where you can get gas you know
what i'm saying
you can smell one from the other place
you know
that just bleeds in the gas bleeds into
the cheese
you know he doesn't know the little does
our producer nick know that i have a
huge insurance policies out on him
brother
he used to work at bronson's comedy club
did you really no he did oh yeah nick
did huh yeah so i'm back in the day oh
wow oh yeah you told me you worked there
for one week and they had two great
comedians that came through who were
they sebastian and jay larson wow
yeah someone uh someone jumped off uh
it's on them have you ever been there
yeah yeah yeah so it's on like the third
level and looks over into an atrium so
the day i was uh performing there i
walked in on a thursday night someone
had jumped off
and committed suicide right uh before
the show with the line of people waiting
to get in so
it's a nice start to the week
dude i got caught up there they had a ch
i mean that's crazy at a mall
go outdoors
you like your mustang
yeah maybe the parking garage yeah have
some respect for shoppers for your
fellow shoppers right right in the
middle where they have the santa claus
set up oh so yeah it's been good though
what are you gonna wear dude how like i
am
the outfits are uh
next next
next week
i mean i'm not gonna come out there in a
see-through leopard nipple shirt
how many gross of sequins are in the
mail right now out of here
headed to los angeles to make your
costume brother there might be a
sequined jacket or two but you better
come out
looking like a 60 year old italian thot
who's trying to [ __ ] get one last run
and some [ __ ] over at the vfw you know i
want to reel i want you to come out just
shining bro there's going to be a lot of
yeah i think i'm the pro maybe one of
the oldest hosts they've ever had at
least the maybe the only host they've
ever had with gray hair
definitely yeah
so uh and you might be one of the only
those who's being honest about their age
as well yeah you know that's one thing
that is nice about italians like if they
really they dress up you almost dress
for anything
it could be something severe it could be
a good you know it could be a
get-together it could be a funeral it
could be uh indictment
you know
all the above yeah it's like they dress
they're well dressed well i won best
dressed in high school you really yeah
senior year i took uh well i actually
got the there was a tie between me and
another guy i should have i should have
took it home though but i was really
actually upset that i had to share the
award with the guy but yeah always
always uh
very particular about how we look and i
think it stemmed from you know the
upbringing i would come down
to go out my mother's like where you
going with that on i'm like well i'm
gonna go we're gonna go to dinner and
see like that go put you know go put
some nice slacks on yeah and um you're
like dude mom we're going to arby's ma
yeah we don't go to ireland
we're going to pizza remember when pizza
was sit down
they said that sit down anymore no i
would merge the basket robinson [ __ ]
some of them you go in there it's just
some muppet just gives you a scoop of
[ __ ] pepperoni bro
and somebody pulls a gun in the distance
bro that place is going downhill that
you can't sit down and eat there anymore
you can bro
you're not gonna be [ __ ] looked at
well it's very small in there
was your tipping point where did you
take off on this well i went on rogan's
one time and i was just like man um
people just
want to hear people talk about stuff and
it kind of gave me just a different
perception of what podcasting was
and so then
yeah then i just started in my kitchen
and it was just kind of like yeah i'm
just going to talk about stuff that's
going on you know and sometimes it
struggles sometimes it's not i can
imagine yours probably has more recipes
in it i could see there's a recipe or
two um there's a lot of recipes actually
um but yeah it's we have fun with it
it's it's it's a really really good
podcast it's just i wish
it would reach a broader audience we
don't really put a lot of time and
energy into it um because you know it's
just he's there i'm here right um so and
you've got a big life going on now well
yeah i mean i have a family and whatnot
not that there's an excuse not to have a
podcast but uh dude i hope my father one
day leaves me for a podcast
[Laughter]
imagine how sad the stories are going to
be for our children
yeah my dad was never home he was always
an encino recording
he never took me to ballet class because
he was in podcastville
uh
that's gonna be a lot of kids stories
though
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]